bon deuxième équipe du tremplin c'est
bien une équipe puisque ce sont les
missiles à boulimie cible pour ce petit
bout de papier qui peut tout acheter
je vois aires pour deux mois n'importe
quoi pour toucher quelques billets rêver
tout le monde sera tête
collet
aidez nous
mon césar et dollars
mais oui tenté pour ça que dollars elle
m'avait promis de mai mais même à moitié
fauché mais d'autres avaient ce que moi
moi je n'ai pas et cambriolages ou tél
c'est vrai l'amour pc mac et bruxelles
pour se compter le monde à bras raquette
en lin ça me fait rigoler
j'aimais bien
avec la wii en pays d'auch voilà
vraiment je trouve qu'il ya vraiment une
très bonne idée une idée originale ça
accroche beauchemin c'est bien ça hier
dans le problème des sous des sous
hier vers nous et évidemment c'est pas
très juste vis-à-vis de nathalie de gand
qui est tout seul contre quatre
mais je crois qu'ils sont déjà assez
bien en place et intéressant il avait le
lyonnais retrouve également qu'ils sont
très au point qu'ils accrochent déjà
très bien
yves réponse qui progresse d'un grand
prix progressent dans le grand prix bien
alors 3e galop d'essai